okay hello everyone welcome to another
open language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series and we have a variety of topics
today
okay real value number Q variable
numeric Q
right so this is I mean there there's
you know I just wanted to bring this is
mostly Doc review and I you know there
are a couple of points I wanted to just
emphasize the you know that became a bit
clearer from our discussion last time
but uh why was it called real valued
rather than just real number cue
before
uh we decided against that because uh it
won't necessarily have head real
oh
God
okay
um
yeah well exact results the required
simplification may be missed yeah we're
welcome to it's like the um possible
zero queue and so on right I mean this
is you know this isn't a a right so
basically you know this is documented as
a possible issue and I just wanted to
make sure we're all okay with that
undecidability is the thing we have to
live with them I mean
yes I I do have a quick question about
this if that's okay
so I think Rob and I have slightly
different opinions about this so so the
way it works now is
real value numeric queue just as a low
Precision approximation
of the quantity checks if what it gets
is a number and if that number is uh
is real the floating Point real but
that's kind of that's kind of a very
weak kind of um
notion of a numeric object I mean
some time ago Stephen you wanted equal
to try harder in the cases where it
couldn't be decided with a simple
numeric evaluation and it does other
things like call
root reduce for example to try and do
some sort of
what at least what it can do
to do some kind of symbolic
simplification of the thing to actually
uncover whether it is
right so it's easy to tell if if you
evaluate it at low Precision it has a
great big whopping complex you know uh
imaginary then fine then fine the point
is what do we do when we fall back we
could do something a little bit more
elaborate when we fall back so if we do
a numerical evaluation and it is zero
then we could do a bit more work like we
do with equal
so I could add a test to say try and
find the imaginary part of this thing
this numeric object and see if that's an
exact zero yeah yeah I don't think that
would be good so I have a branch that
does that but the question is do we want
to try harder do you think that's a
reasonable thing to do and I think I
mean a reasonable thing to do so long as
it doesn't burn a lot of time it won't
burn time in the case where it's
definitely not you know like you said
where the imaginary part is non-zero
then it won't burn time okay what about
the what about the case where it's
symbolic
it won't do anything because you check
the numeric flag so it will do the same
work as if you did like M of something
equals equals zero that's the kind of
fallback case that it goes to so it
won't be any more complicated than that
or any more expensive than that
well and I think it's worth doing
okay
I mean it's I mean I kind of like that
because it also if somebody puts like an
up like they make a a constant or
something their own constant and they
Define
in Lay right and up value that's saying
like the imaginary part of this constant
is zero they want to make it real value
then this will pick that up because it
will go through the evaluator it won't
because it won't have a numeric flag
unless they got that right
yeah but they would have to set the
numeric flag on their constant if if if
they've done that properly they've set
it up properly so if it it would pick up
some sort of up value definition on the
thing
this is actually doing a little less
work than m whatever equals zero because
that will make us some effort in the
symbolic case
right yes
right so so it's kind of circumventing
any symbolic stuff and only doing the
numeric stuff by pre-testing it so the
Americas question right yes good point
it sounds pretty safe yeah it sounds
sensible to me okay
but wait a minute does it what's its
Criterion for when it gives up I mean
because we have dollar
what is it called that the thing that
the equals extra Precision oh yeah right
yeah I mean that's that's what it's
going to try internally it will try
something like that fine and then then
it will give up in the same way and if
you reset extra Precision you can get
this to have more stuff out exactly
fine
sounds sensible to me okay okay
give me a day or two and I'll set up a
PR that uh
sounds good
um
I don't think I really need to read the
documentation I assume you'll knit it on
on guide Pages or maybe that will have
to come back to me in a separate meeting
you can click on those links and I'll
open the page
well I tried that it didn't work
that's unfortunate
but this should surely link to real
okay and we also link back to it
oh yeah okay
I should say is determined to be a
number with a real value
or something
but it should make it clear that it's
actually might do something that isn't
completely trivial that is you know I
mean well you you clicked on number Q
which is something completely trivial
right
I mean it checks that it's
a number and it has oh actually I see
sorry yeah yeah numeric Q is the
oh it did work that one did work
well that's it yeah
all right seems reasonable I mean it
could settle a bit more clearly I think
though
that
okay all right on to the next item
um which means Robin Rock could deposit
no they can't yeah I don't think there's
anything else for me unless I'm mistaken
well actually there is one there okay I
missed that though I'll hang around I'll
I'll go and get somebody tweet and come
back in a minute
yeah that's fine
right so overdot was kind of funky and I
fixed some bugs in it and there's this
undocumented second argument and now
that everything's working correctly I
figure maybe we should document it
you mean the multi the the very Dotty
dotted that's right so you can do
overdot of you know X comma two and I'll
give you two dots and you can do X comma
three and it'll give you three dots
for it does not know about
well
a number of dots only goes up to three
that's absolutely bizarre well I mean
there's no character that has I don't
believe there's any character with four
dots so
but I mean but there's a fourth flexion
derivative
is this a character surely not yes this
is absolutely a character that's the
character called the triple Dot
just like this uh
oh gosh and it's not just a
an assembly of dots
correct
like a flock of dots or or a pride of
dots or something
well I think it could be John do you see
any reason why this can't be a
synthesized object
with just you know
strong with us
um he was invited
um is John here I could see where John's
at I don't see him on the meeting
I think it should synthesize out of dots
if you go to above three
um
okay I mean it'll
right it'll get very big very fast right
I mean those three dots are about are
about one character wide whereas that
thing is five characters wide I kept it
I mean my obviously will be compressed I
don't know I mean
we could start stacking vertically
or would that be too weird no yeah okay
no I mean I I don't think people really
use more than three dots they probably
don't it's just the type of system we
have does not usually have restrictions
like you can have any number of dots if
the number is less than three
yeah it's less than four not less than
three okay okay okay okay but
still I just think we should have
something where it synthesizes it and
squashes them together
it's not a difficult piece of code
um
okay and let's wait for John to show up
and then he can he can comment on that
okay yeah well we need John's here yeah
sorry it wasn't on my calendar
okay we've got over dot which has a
number of dots parameter and apparently
the only characters go up to three dots
but I'm saying we should allow any
number of dots and we should just
synthesize that out of out of dots which
have been crushed together so to speak
and I'm skeptical of that because I
don't know how you crush multiple dots
together I mean in in the texty world
right this is a purely textual object
so
yeah
I mean John don't you do it with
I don't know
I'm well uh the the triple one is uh is
actually literally uses the triple dot
character yeah I know so I'm just saying
why isn't the why isn't this just using
this comma five and then spacing of I
don't know spacings of I don't know
minus one or something that doesn't work
well spacer
so uh I mean what about the outlier
cases where the either the dots
overwrite one another or the dots are
wider than the the character
then you have to have them white in that
character I mean it's like anything else
which Stacks up but the thing could have
a you know a big hat all hat no
forget how that expression goes you know
it's all hat then if you get what I'm
saying
it's it's the cattle that's lacking
yeah I mean well what if you but try
putting a negative thin space
as uh as the second argument Arrow there
well let's just do negative thick space
just for fun okay oh boy that eight it's
that eight it's um what's your
matriculate it's quote yep
yeah fine I mean
okay
um I guess what we should do and if the
thing ends up with a
um you know if that ends up being
overscript
you know that has a definite
okay I mean that that's obvious one
thing that's not going to be typable
unlike the 2.3 Dot case
which I mean
is fine I mean we certainly do have
things where you can type in some cases
and not other cases we're going heavily
to all hat with a lack of we could we
really have lack of body it's a it's
good it's gone beyond Sombrero to uh
yeah right
so so so here's here's something you
should be aware of
how do I get to an emoji
uh you can type in uh
zero one f600
backslash what pipe
well that wasn't the Emoji I was looking
forward it doesn't really matter that's
uh okay that's a heavily
um go ahead what we're gonna say John
okay okay so so in a new cell type uh X
control seven Dot
okay now uh uh cursor out of that
and type right next to it X control
seven dot dot
notice the slightly different vertical
uh uh uh spacing there
and that's because period is
specifically recognized as a uh I forget
what we call it but uh but basically as
a as a character that can be kind of
scrunched into an overscript
why aren't we turning any number of dots
into an over dot
with that with that numbered a numbered
over dot
so I'm I I'm just saying that this
Behavior this is C plus plus behavior
that would have to be changed
um okay well I think it says right so if
you did if you did double dot there
right you'd get the scrunched Behavior
again I think that's correct yes
right so I think there's a mild I mean
this is not our most critical thing but
I think it would be mildly nice if this
thing if you type a whole bunch of dots
it would turn into an over dot comma and
then that number
yeah double dot is lining up perfectly
with DOT
so
so I think that's a mildly useful thing
okay that does a reasonable thing though
just goes off the side
right can we go on
well I I guess the question is so are we
not documenting until we change the
front-end Behavior
no we can document with the current
front-end Behavior okay
item margins
yes and this is going to be more John's
show than mine yeah this particular item
well and unfortunately I don't have a
really good solution here I'm
uh I I'm I'm kind of I'm kind of at a
loss for this
um and you'll forgive me because I'm not
I did not knowing about the meeting I
didn't even have my own copy of the
agenda open but uh yeah so that we had
talked about
um uh item margins before and the notion
that we could generalize uh we talked
about item margins specifically for item
but it was suggested that we could
generalize item margins for uh as a as
an option to uh to grid box or to grid
um and that's not unreasonable but there
is an ambiguity doesn't appear for item
but it appears for grid
um
and uh and the problem is you know the
the the nesting levels it's basically
the ambiguity is is caused by on the one
hand uh the use of uh list uh list
braces to indicate uh uh you know this
is something that might be a part of a
repeating pattern in Grid yes
but on the other hand you might also
want to specify
uh the left margin and the right margin
as separate values or as one combined
value and if they're separate values you
wrap our list brace around them
output values
yeah right
okay
walk me through this I'm not I'm not
clear um right right okay so the
um
uh so it could have been interpreted as
either a left right item margin which
only applies to the first column
okay or
it might have been interpreted as a uh
uh as a repeating specification
where uh the Left Right values are both
one for the First Column they're both
two for the second column they're both
one for the third column two for the
fourth column Etc etcetera
oh my gosh I don't know what I mean the
basic Point here is
this is for bulk specifying the margins
or an item in a grid by the way I item
is also supported in row correct
no
um no
supported in column because it's a
column lives in the grid world but Roe
lives in like the texty world
that's really horrifying
I mean yes and we we
repeatedly
uh raised the point of how horrified it
was when you designed it
well row is very useful
well it's not that not that we were
opposed to the idea of a thing that does
what Roe does but the the name you know
row and column are just totally
different things but they look like they
should be parallel to one another well
in what ways are they different
rho is not a table
it is not a grid box column is a grid
box
yeah okay but operationally what does
that mean what options do they have in
the differ that they have they have no
options in common basically basically
yeah I mean you know aside from totally
generic options like base Style
there's virtually nothing in common
right I a rho is much more similar to
the old sequence form than I mean it's
basically a slightly repackaged version
of sequence form than it is anything
like grid whereas column is basically uh
with this forwarding notebook what was
that something is horribly horribly slow
in this prototype build you saw that
right yes I did
and this is horribly slow as well this
is what I was talking about yesterday
Tom
um
was just ignoring it but this is yeah
unbelievably slow every action here is
unbelievably slow there's something
wrong
look at this I'm trying to resize it
it's unbelievably slow it's spinning see
that
well we can't see that it's spinning
okay there's no spinner for us okay fine
but I'm telling you that was I mean I I
I I I I I I I agree it's slow but it's
really nice
okay well I don't know but but it's been
slow for me for the last few like week
or two okay that that time it was faster
right
there's something I mean some somebody
added some stupid thing
okay any case
alignment background Baseline style and
bass style default elements
an empty item
how come we even have an empty item here
well if you if you edit it then you
might and delete the contents you might
end up with an empty item
yeah
you won't end up with one originally
created
unless
yeah okay I mean I know if you do raw
boxes of emphasis interpreted as an
empty I mean I mean that is the basic
design of grid box though that when you
empty it out it doesn't actually leave
it necessarily as an empty string it
leaves it as a visible placeholder that
you can go back and select later
yeah of course you could change default
element to be empty string if you wanted
to but that's not the default yeah I
understand divide is it's not present in
row
right correct
an image margins is present in row but
not in column
I've never been entirely sure what image
size and image margins doing well I
think image size and image margins I
think they're basically about those
frame they're related to those frame
options uh
how come this has rounding radius and
column does not have around gradients
okay well because row is doing nothing
more than a frame box
and frame boxes support rounding
okay but grids do not support rounding
that's a shame uh invite to Loop but if
somebody could try there there is a
useful there is a fundamental ambiguity
in uh when you're talking about rounding
for grids because
uh which Corners get the round
if it's only the outer Corners then you
could have just wrapped the frame box
around the whole thing and and you know
that would have been fine if you want to
start rounding the inner Corners what
does that even mean I'm sorry how could
you have done that because it doesn't
the the grid line right the grid framed
of grid
because that doesn't work does it but if
I say we we have a fully composable
language framed of grid totally works
I'm going to demonstrate why it doesn't
well here I want to get the frames of
all places other than the outer frame
rounding problem is well defined on the
outer frame the rounding problem is not
defined at all on the inner frame which
are obvious if you think about it
I realize I realize that I'm making a
different point how do I get what I'm
saying is I don't think that these are
going to join up correctly if I have
inner
did you get what I'm saying right yes
yes yes that's that's exactly true
what does it do if I say frame to
automatic no what does it do for frame
and and and and and and what if you want
to create rounding that's just around a
column or a row no uh but it's crazy
yeah it is exactly but I mean having
these Corners be rounded is doable
yes
but we've never done it because uh
well I mean you know we could just
because they have a fully because we
have a fully generic language
the special cases
it's a big it's a big special case just
pretend that we're not a general
language here then we can do it yeah no
no no no no no no no I'm asking a simple
question I want the thing to just have
uh divider lines that go to the outer
boundary here but then I want there to
be rounding on that corner is that you
see what I'm saying see there
right yeah I mean we understand what
you're we're saying and and we're just
throwing your argument about you know
two three dots back at you right that
would be rounding that only apply to you
know four of the you know N squared or
so Corners in okay I understand I I get
the point
I'm just saying you can't reproduce the
thing that I wanted purely with uh
you're saying rounding radius is hard to
justify not applying but but rounding
radius was available in row but how does
it work in row it uses a frame box
because the only only frame you can have
in row is a frame that wraps the entire
row right there's no such thing as
dividers in row because it's not a grid
like construct
what what does dividers do doesn't
divide us change the um here if I say
dividers
arrow green or something
well I you can use true and false I mean
I don't recall the exact precedence of
frame versus divider when they're both
yeah specified yeah
frame I mean frame and dividers is a bit
weird and it's if I recall correctly I
think it's
uh
uh is there a frame there might even be
a weirder frame specification than than
what we've already discussed what's the
difference between dividers and the
frame Arrow all I don't understand why
the divided oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
frame actually gets worse because in
Grid you can give frame an element wise
frame specification
or or row wise or a column specification
okay so what are we discussing here so
so so we couldn't even say that routing
radius only applies to frame because
there are all kinds of frames it
couldn't apply to
there are all kinds of frame
specifications I should say that it
couldn't apply to okay okay fine all
right so what's the issue what what's
your
okay surprise row doesn't have a
spacings option even though it's second
I think it should have a spacings option
there's no reason I mean it's not
difficult to put it in
that's that's what the uh uh the second
argument of row effectively I know I
know but it's not quite the same in fact
it's documented right there spacer as an
option spacer has a value for the second
argument no I know I know I use it all
the time
but it's fundamentally different units
right I mean the second argument gives
you right spacer gives you a distance in
points whereas I don't know what units
spacings use but it's certainly not
points
um
okay
horizontally it's M's vertically
vertically it's line spacings
but that will be a reason to have a
spacings option for row so you could get
an M's based spacing nice and
consistently with column
well in the modern world the conversion
between M's and points is pretty
is pretty straightforward
if you know the font size if if you know
the ambient font size
yeah but why
why would we not have a spacings option
for row
other than just obviousness
I mean it just seems like yes you can
put the second argument in and it works
with a particular you know it works
nicely but why not have the consistency
of having spacings as an option for row
as well well for one thing it wouldn't
uh it would have a confusing meaning
uh the the spacings if I recall
correctly I think the spacings is uh
I'm not sure that it's the full spacing
but and it is and what happens if you
specify both spacings and a
okay and uh the delimiter then what the
spacing mean
yeah I assume that they would compose
on which side or both both
okay okay so sorry spacings is the apps
defined as the absolute space between
items independent of the presence of
frames or dividers
okay so that means which you can't do in
row so that means that it I mean if we
had a spacings option you know in the
same way that we split the space in a
grid on the left side of the divider and
the right side divider we would also
have to split it on the left side and
the right side of the second argument of
row
sure
what's wrong with that is that what you
expected
is that useful
I'm not sure
if if that is that even doable
look if the default for the second
argument is no space at all which is I
think what it is right it's default for
the second argument is an empty string
yeah
I think right which means that spacings
would give the actual spacing because
it's the additional space added on
beyond the the second argument space
uh no I don't think that's right I mean
that's exactly what we were just saying
right uh space the spacings option means
the space between the elements
irrespective of you know a divider or
anything else that's between them
okay so that so what you're saying is
if there was a space if there was a
spacer for example that spacer could be
ignored because space sings has a higher
priority so to speak
but if okay but what what if the second
argument is you know vertical bar
then it's still ignored in other words
spacings is determining where the things
get placed independent of what's between
them
Independence
that's what it said
that's what it said that's what it said
for the grid case and that means if you
put big thick dividers in the grid and
you have spacings to be very small the
thing is going to crash into the divider
am I right
um
sure to the extent that
you know
well I I guess I I guess my basic point
is you're insisting on consistency
between things which are fundamentally
inconsistent and live in different
worlds I mean row row is like robots
it's like typing in right then I
understand but I don't think and and you
understand no you know for example that
you know if you just do you know
something like what I put in chats uh
row of ABC with second argument comma
you're going to see something
interesting
notice that the comma is not placed dead
center
that's a feature
okay
because the idea is to replicate
what would have happened if uh if you
had typed a comma B comma C in a
standard
typeset cell
you want to replicate like operator
spacing for example in this case what
you're seeing is the operator spacing
around the comma which hugs on the left
hand side and spaces out on the right
hand side
all right so this is this is something
that is fundamentally different from
grid where in the case of grid those
dividers they're always dead center
in you know in in the spacing's value
uh well in some sense these you know the
the characters you know this you know
the the kind of box that the characters
are being painted in could be dead
center but the ink is not dead center it
will not look dead center at all
right
well okay fine I'm losing this argument
let's talk about items uh item spacing
item margins okay so if you if you look
at the uh at the documentation for grid
uh the portion
that says
um
yeah yeah so so like you know alternates
between C1 and C2 you see that case
there's the third line yeah that's the
kind of thing that we're running into
it's it's the list braces used as a
repeating pattern
so that's worth crazy anyway
it is I mean you know it's uh
um
you know it we used to have this sort of
problem with image size for example and
we came up with up to so that we could
get rid of some of these you know lists
of lists of lists
specifications redesign because this is
incomprehensible
this and partition you know have the
same kind of you know repeating this and
that and the other thing I mean up to is
really helpful in Partition as well
you know the main difference being I can
actually remember this whereas I can't
remember partition
only has six arguments
but I'm yes but I'm sure like etai would
be the exact opposite can remember
partition but can't remember this so
yeah I'm just gonna say I can remember
this up to
you know having to deal with horizontal
horizontal and vertical and
yeah right so so Mike right so I I was
muted when I asked this question and and
therefore was surprised if nobody
answered it so it's a why don't we have
this ambiguity elsewhere is that because
we're taking non-listy things like
exactly Graphics directives exactly yeah
so yeah so it doesn't come up with
directives because well we have
directive to deal with that problem
uh it's uh all of the other options just
happen to be things that either uh
provide a natural rapper like directive
or
uh they they don't have you know they
don't have values where you know if it's
a list it means a and if it's not a list
it means B uh is this is so it's just
kind of a coincidence of the options
that we expect and how they work
the truth is one day we should have a
rapper that means cyclic
that would be that would have been
really useful
if we had thought of that in in 2006
I think that's what we should consider
and I think we should consider it for
partition and this and a whole bunch of
other things
and that way as we build out more syntax
here we can build it out with that
so
we can Implement item margins on item
today but we can't Implement item
margins on grid because of this
ambiguity
um are we okay with temporarily having
item margins only on item I think it's
okay so okay
but then let's put in our agenda I mean
it'll take quite a bit of discussion the
cyclic thing because there's a lot of
issues with cyclic parts and cyclic lots
of things yeah but I think it's a good
thing for us to look at
and that's a specific direction that I
can work up a proposal around and of
course you might hate the first version
of proposal but we can iterate fine do
we need to discuss the units
um
the uh the the units is
a bit problematic but it wasn't as
deadly as the uh as the ambiguity
problem
um
so I mean it just comes back around to
this you know M's versus points or line
Heights versus what do we want to do I
mean uh it doesn't plot margins plot
margins is in points
you mean right grid is grid is just
about the only thing
that uses line Heights and ends I
right grid and the grid spawned things I
think a column I think it needs to I
think otherwise it's not going to look
right if if you increase the font size
you want to change well and and we've
long talked about the possibility of of
having a unit specification where you
could you know go either way you saw
have to you know uh along with me in 20
years we've been talking about that yes
yes
I mean it's a problem that we you know
if we were willing to have a simple
solution it could would not require 20
years of effort by any stretching the
imagination but it kind of got lost in
you know the generalities of uh well you
know units in the front end but I mean
what if what if you want to specify your
your your size in parsecs or something
like that you know
I roll
I I want to do it in furlongs
yeah based on the absolute size of your
screen
okay but seriously here
the consistent thing is M's and line
Heights is that true it's consistent
within grid uh item it claims it's being
used in a few other places where it
would be less consistent but in fact I I
think the item documentation like item
claims it can be used in overlay and and
I looked and it that's just not true it
may have we may have wanted it to be
through but it's just not true
um
what does it do with manipulate I sorry
I don't remember what it does with
manipulates
um
yeah I I I I you know obviously had
something
I'm sorry why did overlay want it
um
all right right I believe it's used to
manipulate for
um for like control placement and and
you know sizing yes I I think you're
right I think you're right
um I I did play with it sorry it's just
been a while I don't remember I did play
with it manipulate and and it did kind
of work and manipulate but not as
consistently as you might have expected
um but overlay is just completely
non-functional and the idea being that
you could specify you know separate like
margins or whatever for each element of
the overlay it's not necessarily a bad
idea but nobody's asked for it nobody's
reported bugs on it I'm in tempted to
just de-documented yeah
okay unmanipulate basically the point is
that the content area this is moving
around the content area no this is not
the content area this is a control area
oh
so what's the idea for using the
manipulate
so if if you are like creating uh oh a
custom row of controls or something like
that uh you know it basically remember
you could use grid to to set you know to
to customize your uh your control area
manipulate I mean you know we don't
usually but it is possible to do quite a
level of customization of how the
controls lay out and this is part of
that
and if you're going to push for more
details sorry I don't remember off top
of my head
but that's the hand wavingly General
answer
okay
um
all right so what uh okay so here's uh
trying to find in the documentation is
problematic but here's an example I just
copied from the documentation
of the usage of item and manipulate
okay
and in the in this particular case it's
uh setting an alignment for a specific
uh
uh label that's in the control area
right
that's useful
and I can see why we want it the overlay
um yeah
it it makes sense it's just that no one
ever implemented it yeah in these cases
M's and
uh line Heights or fine units I think
for a case like this fine unit for a
case like this we don't want absolute
points in a case like this
so we're good yeah okay
I I mean I think overlay would be one of
those slow implementation type things
yeah but by slow I mean you know
well I think I I think I have plenty of
Direction now to proceed so all right so
thank you
okay emphasized
are we happy with the name a little
weird to me that it's red you know
yeah we talked about having potentially
other forms of emphasis in the future
um you know again this was the one that
used to be called underlighted which was
the name we made up for
the red squiggly line and we didn't like
red squiggly line obviously
or underlighted emphasis we could call
it squiggleed
maybe that's two or squiggled
yeah emphasized is a bit weird to me
because of the relationship to HTML
which uses the EM tag
meaning
emphasized and uh while you can
customize what the emtag actually does I
think the typical thing is to italicize
[Music]
under squiggled
I think people do call it squiggly line
I mean that seems to be a pretty common
on the squiggle this bit weird
it's a worm that was anesthetized never
mind yeah
between those two options I would go
with squiggled me too
what is it competing with what are the
other things like this
brains
well it's it's more similar to
highlighted right so I mean this is a
question that we didn't actually really
discuss last time or not didn't discuss
very fully that uh right so the way
emphasized was implemented it disappears
on interpretation like
um like highlight it does like
highlighted does which is different from
the default behavior of framed or style
which you know remember where they came
from right so if you were to copy that
percent 31 then
use it as input it would still be framed
whereas if you did that four percent
Thirty it would
um right so when you evaluate that
that's going to disappear
but if you do that with framed the
output then the frame will be remembered
obviously right for highlighted doesn't
seem right to me
I want output that is highlighted that
was its main point
and that's specifically how we designed
it when we came up with highlighted is
we wanted something that was transparent
for evaluation really why
as far as I remember I mean I'd have to
dig it up a little bit but I believe the
idea was that we wanted to be able to do
inline markup that wasn't going to
change the evaluation of the code
I certainly agree that the inconsistency
between framed and highlighted is uh uh
eyebrow raising
right I mean yeah it's it's uh
I don't like it I I think it's wrong I
think highlighted disappearing is wrong
okay
uh can we go find out I don't I don't I
don't I don't disagree with you I will
just point out that you are disagreeing
with yourself from a year or two ago
when he designed highlighted well so but
you might be yes you might be right but
I'm disagreeing with myself but yeah I
mean we could we could change the
defaults and then just have it respect a
strip on input
option right yes
I think that's what we should do I think
it's really wrong right now I think it's
very useful to be able to it's just
crazy it's just crazy I mean if I say
something like
you know
I don't know rain you know
um
you know if Prime Q highlighted
otherwise identity
oh God
you got what I'm saying right yeah
that works
well why does that work
why does that okay because that's only
specifically on the typeset form so if
you copied that and evaluated it all of
those would still have head integer
whereas
if you took those results my God
that's crazy
super confusing
okay
yeah we can change that
yeah now in terms of squiggles
right so for if if we're if we're
changing and if we're changing the
behavior of
highlighted then squiggle should also be
like framed and all the other types of
generators great but now strip on input
so with these with strip on input be an
explicit option to highlight it
I think so sure yeah
it's a it's an option to framed so is it
yeah so if you copy that
it's not a documented option A Frame
though
ah okay
what is it documented for
good question
I think it's documented for boxes
okay
it's a documented for style that's
another place
I had no idea you could use it that
generally
how does it relate to the difference
it's not documented for style either we
should document it there too
do we like the name
I like the name I mean I I wouldn't
claim to be I I wouldn't claim to be
totally in love with the name but I
think it's a reasonable name and it's
one we've had for a long time so yeah
there's one we've had for a long time in
the in the low level box world
mm-hmm yeah
how does it relate to things like defer
which by the way should be referenced
here
um Lou does the fur you strip on input
or does it just have a direct
interpretation function
I mean it relates to defer in that the
thing that you're constructing as output
can be used as input in some way other
than what the output would generally be
interpreted as so that's why I think it
should they should be cross-referenced
right yes it's it's conceptually related
it's not technically related okay but
but now
is strip on input an appropriate option
or should it be some kind of wrapper
or is that
I think that's crazy yeah it's an option
to the specific function right that the
problem is that a wrapper is you know
it's ambiguous unless you're willing to
say strip everything in which case it
may start way too much yeah okay
yep
um but I'm happy to go through and clean
up the documentation added to things
like style and framed and such
I'm just thinking is there any other
name other than strip on input I mean
strip on input is very clear
right
all right fine that's what we should do
I think this should be renamed squiggled
okay
um this one comment is this something to
be named after what it does or how it
does it because in a sense highlighted
is not color it's not colored or
yellowed
well what is this doing
well it's typically used to mark an
error a mistake
so you're suggesting a name like marked
or uh
red pen
I don't know I just want to offer no no
that's a reasonable point it's a
reasonable point right
what is it called what's that mistaken
that's really weird
lagged
that's horrifying
I mean so many flags out there waving
around yes
markup would be too General yep
what what do you think it's called in in
word processes
I've never seen a name ascribed to it in
word processors
um
somewhere but not in the interface
though right I mean the closest to it is
and you know it's been years since I've
looked at this so my memory is fuzzy but
right there's usually some sentence like
you know
indicate misspelled words or highlight
misspelled words but they never refer to
the actual
squiggling thing well okay so that is
the concept of redlining but that's a
little bit of a different thing
yes I mean I think it came from this
Maybe
right and it obviously has poor social
connotations these days no it does oh my
God
oh my God I think Windows refers to at
least the parameter for the color is
spelling wavy underline color
so
I'm wavy is better than squiggled I
suppose
[Music]
um
we could call it misspelled well I just
came across a seven page NIH document uh
which is guidelines for spelling error
annotations in consumer health texts
and in seven pages it doesn't
name it yeah it doesn't name it
um
let's see
um attention
no way that's like an attention layer
yeah
warning warning the uh
yeah I mean I you know I have to say
you're I was a bit surprised at your
level of resistance to flagged I didn't
think that flagged was terrible
the reason I don't like it is because
you know in code you're always talking
about flagging things and bits and you
know
right I I I I I mean I I
I'm a bit concerned right because
there's you know flags and codes and
obviously there are physical flags of
Nations and whatnot
um
so I'm not sure it has all together to
write connotations
um
let's see
personally I'm not loving any of these
better than squiggled
right
um and you know just like we have I mean
granted it's a named style rather than
the head right but obviously we have
like underlined it has a profound thing
for it to say
squiggly line or let's quickly line
[Music]
um
yes not to be confused with the green
squiggly line that is you know allegedly
flagging uh grammar errors
I thought you were going to say that was
flagging correctly spelled words
uh no
that's not right
um I love the way it's so definitive and
what it says
anyway
um
well good to know the robots aren't
going to replace us quite yet
uh
well what about an annotation word
well obviously we have annotation which
is a much more General thingy
um so
we need to be careful not to muddy that
um
oh boy the thing is off
talking about
a uh a rapper
oh I am glad that the um the the
highlighting is working now that's nice
but the um
uh
colorings work in those boxes
um
okay
let's see
annotated no that's awful because we've
already got 60 million things called
annotated
um what are some other words flagged
um
I need to go
commented
um
well you know the advantage of squiggles
people will mostly know what it means
all right I guess school is probably the
best we've got
certainly better than emphasized
okay
all right
I gotta go and we got through the 13-3
material yep so sorry for making you
hang around Mark and Tom but I I guess
I'll just discuss this we'll have this
discussion some other time
sorry guys okay
okay
see you soon okay thank you yeah okay
bye everyone